[Music]
the end is near I never thought I would
be this desperate playing Minecraft I
feel disgusted in myself I realized I'm
at the lowest point of what any man has
ever experienced but this is bigger than
me god damn it
this is bigger than all of us and
therefore I have come to play Minecraft
Christian servers the subject is almost
at 10000 there's no one left to save us
now jacksepticeye has showed his support
but it wasn't enough markiplier has
showed us a part of our life at a walk
[Music]
even Logan Paul ended his head but it
wasn't enough countless people in the
community has helped but it wasn't
enough we have one last chance I'm
putting all my cards into this game
minecraft say it with me browse
minecraft minecraft let's freakin go I
wish I had sunglasses because I think
that would have been cool hey guys
what's up
we're playing Minecraft Christian server
that's why were here to finish this off
once and for all
okay so I don't really know any I have
not played minecraft in a very long time
so I don't really know what that looks
like I mean I don't know how to play
basically you're gonna get banned from
minecraft
not on my watch kid I got knocked on my
side it's not gonna happen
yeah I came back home from vacation
yesterday I came home early to stop T
series you playing minecraft before yeah
like 10 years ago buddy relax
just don't say heck or Frick [ __ ] I just
did
holy [ __ ] oh it's MX I don't know what
currency that is but thank you very much
slice okay let's just listen let's just
jump into it question mark okay so I
already had Christians save Eko and I
hope that I can I got banned it's okay
that's okay
okay I have other questions servers to
join it's fine
there's many questions servers out thing
all right Christian server the number
one critic a this is supposed to be the
number one Christian server it's not
ranked number one bit
well god damn it do they have a band
list they son of a snakes there they
have gospel gospel craft please outdated
server well [ __ ] what I don't think is
this hard to connect to in Minecraft
what is Stace I was playing just fine a
second ago there we go yes we're in boys
we're in Minecraft Christian server save
with me boys
minecraft Christian server were in we're
in welcome sub 2 P 2 pi all right we
need to find other fellow man crafters
what's up fellow friends we're playing
it safe here right I don't want to get
Bane okay so far we're not going so far
so good
I think this is good I think this means
we're winning I'm not gonna get bang I'm
not gonna get bang why is no one talking
to me brand they see breath is that a
reference oh god there's furries in
there has everyone subbed or are other
people joined already stop hitting your
pregnant wife this is supposed to be
Christian God I don't know what I'm
doing it so I guess I have the arm where
am I putting it on okay people are
hitting the ice I assume this is don't
get banned this time we're doing fine
what's the server eiders I'm not gonna
say it because you guys gonna nuke the
server if the ones who saw it saw it
alright that's only gonna sing why
aren't people attacking me
no don't attack me thought this is
Christian server I thought this was
Christian server what the hell get away
you're supposed to help any point you're
supposed to help him right that server
leave me alone help help help help you
in the name of Jesus
stop why am I not taking damage I'm
trying to run for you how do I run how
do I run in this again I got shield back
on btfo fat oh I ain't doing the fire
stuff
I ain't doing that how do I get out of
here this is crazy they're crazy control
oh thank you oh I got a live
oh god it's laggy ah stop like W 2 times
what do you think I'm not I'm not an
epic game where I'm running away from
them this is it
this is it boys [ __ ] why did it [ __ ] is
your problem
stop hitting me and everyone that place
is [ __ ] I'm trying to Christian here
but you guys are making it really
[ __ ] hard stop
white alert everyone running after me
not gonna pvp ten lag goes what lang
what are you talking about it do you
speak English Christians Jesus Christ I
mean I'm sorry Peter I'll help thank you
I'm gonna get out of here this house it
crazy I don't like it this is not the
Minecraft experience I signed up for
okay ultra fast some tape it might
what's that boy what's the sub-game
13000 it's kind of working keep
subscribing through hashtag spawn okay
you're not allowed to you just come in
while you're in combat gee thanks a lot
screw this
alright I'm done with Christmas servers
just getting a back invoice I expect
this to be the biggest livestream of all
the time considering I'm playing I can't
connect literally they're that many
people connect
looks like a what's like a good server
then hit me up in the chat boys we're
gonna have to try another one failed I'm
looking at the top ten Christian server
minecraft server list how they did
server and gospel crap didn't work right
this is so sad I'm a ban from I'm banned
from Christian crafts like why did I do
wrong
joining we're in bring I'll thank God
oh this is epic okay okay KKK okay oh
god people are joining Oh God so what is
this and why is no-one moving hello
hey look Oh God
join a look it's items oh god don't say
the n-word
please guys this is Mike Ramsay a
Christian server the like the laughs oh
my god I'm not saying the IP clearly
it's already messed up Jesus Christ
since it's Sam's guys what kind of game
runs on control by the way excuse me
alright stop riding furry emotes in the
chat please this is really epic this is
incredible
this is just a Minecraft Christian
experience that I was expecting and it's
gone and it's gone
alright I'm gonna I'm gonna do a new
thing where I don't show which server I
joined because god damn a we will just
nuke servers and I don't want to do that
I was hoping like just two maybe a
couple people caught on I think that
many people would join
God please if God is real then he will
let me join my god I mean you know what
I mean
what surprise how hard it is to connect
to Christian summer I'm joining nope the
number one Christmas server has to work
no connecting come on please Jesus is
real let me join this Christian server
please
please okay
someone linked a server that can support
a lot of players so I'm gonna try and
join this one it's not I want to nuke
you guys okay someone told me that this
server can connect to a lot of people
Mac high embassy dot high pixel Dante
let's go we're in Boise
we're in where I am what am I looking at
oh here we are
this is a this is what the end game
looks like yeah high pixel that's it
we've got people joining pipe pretty
tight oh my god my slave on a Christian
server they have slaves man I've been
doing Christianity wrong man it's not a
Christian server well [ __ ] all right
feel free to do whatever you guys want
then so disappointed what's the what's
the biggest Christian sir god I like how
someone just could drop the n-word right
away in a Christian serving you think
they would have some sort of block for
that kind of thing
game PewDiePie YouTube ranking I really
don't care alright we're here to recruit
people that's why we're here 14,000 it's
working guys I'm getting friend requests
thank God
what do I have I've got : pants
so what exactly do you do on these
amazing Minecraft servers mystery vault
right-click okay what do we get I've
gone to shape
give me a loop box at least there are
freaking [ __ ] how do I get it worse
okay so yeah they have different game
modes is that it mini walls cops and
crimps
that sounds pretty epic or Cade u HC I
was gonna be UFC build battle skywars
TNT games how do I join okay I joined
Jesus Christ
alright so I'll pick them on with the
least in I can't believe I'm playing
[ __ ] Minecraft okay so how does this
work I can be a fire wizard eyes wizard
can wither wizard kinetic okay blood
that smells pretty I think why am i
doing it wrong okay sorry Wow go just
jump down oh my god this is for Steve
right there okay it steams oh god damnit
took a lot of damage
why am i jump someone heal heal
please peace I can't die I don't want to
die in Minecraft I'm too young to die
how do I explode why does everyone have
options
[Music]
[ __ ]
I don't know how to play quite clearly
help me
defense right okay I can use
[Music]
Yeah right click the shoot
guys this is
battle
when I die Jesus points
I'm not sure I understand yeah I do I
take damage for shooting my stuff
ooh look at that game boy back off
minecraft has changed a lot
[Music]
pack your mic off oh my god
I have zero camp out someone else did it
[ __ ] hell
I didn't even hit jump San Jose
automatically and Gemma's on a medical
flight he's quite a guy
right feel with this
[Music]
and I changed clients fire let's go
I'm quietly somebody I mean I settle the
blood one turn off auto jump yeah it's
very annoying
why am I getting
[Music]
this is st. incredible
I don't
Oh God
I'll change after this my salute the
wards
Jesus point though with that chance
Hey look we got it
okay now I change client
got'em is on fire
not today buddy
holy crap I gotta kill guys this changes
the game I'll do another one
Oh actually the Limerick name sorry
let's try another how do I leave
what's there commanded to leave
[Music]
goddamn request
this is not what I
[Music]
god
is it is that Lisa sub-game in its
15,000 bros this is what I'm talking
about
[Music]
look at that I got two kids practically
ready to go for I clearly picked the
wrong class
so easier than the sea well that sounds
like me
[Music]
what a fierce laugh
please Bo
thirty-eight seconds
now I'm not my good clients
I don't know how he'll be working there
it is look at that shot
assault pay state
who's hitting me
that's our red Guyana your John Felix
[Music]
I mean [ __ ] this honestly
Jesus Christ I can't even sit through
two minutes it's so boring
and then I joined and I'm back in but I
can't join this alright you guys tell me
another
let's try lobby no I can't use any
commands
yeah but I'm worried that if I wait that
I will just get back into another game
some [ __ ] which I hope to god doesn't
happen spectator setting play again
return to lobby thank God
right click I'm right clicking oh [ __ ] I
can't see the commands cuz I'm getting
so many requests but I think it's said
like I have to wait three seconds
why is he now letting me Jesus Christ
[ __ ] this I'm back to Christian service
that was way more fun than this at least
I searched Christian server and this
[ __ ] livestream showed up that's not
good okay okay what else I don't know
how many I have left to be on it
okay this one has a Pepe the Frog on it
so I assume it's safe for anyone to join
connecting an incredible experience so
far outdated do I have an outdated
where's the server outdated go check not
sure okay this one works why am i
covering the screen
I shouldn't be denied how's the live
stream look like something glitched out
I don't know what happened I think my
OBS is glitching there we go and it's a
to be the order oh god why come on
minecraft I want to play you thank you
alright I joined oh god which one did I
join play dot cube craft Dante please be
better than all this other [ __ ] [ __ ]
I can't move though oh yeah it's asking
me oh my god sky blocks sky wars cube
craft parkour parkour join me fellow
bros sub gap 15.5 keep subscribing
alright I'm going through these tortured
literally I've already moved but no one
realizes because it's so laggy
stop hitting me
stop we're doing parkour all right at
least that sounds amazing
how do I join you click to join am I
actually easy parkour meeting parkour
hard parkour I'm doing aqua best time no
one knows joining this is it oh my god
this is actually looks really hard what
the [ __ ] Oh Oh God
[Laughter]
what a pic hard okay see it's on tense
not on Christian please I can't see
anything stop moving Oh God
[ __ ] Oh people made a peep no oh
saga fell oh god my fallen brothers we
missed damn bait ah I don't want to live
on this planet anymore I'm doing
shortcut oh god damn it
alright please for the love of God this
hub work thank god hub works he's the
[ __ ] commands work on this one let's
do easy cuz I think it's too hard
click to join I'm not gonna say which
level I joined you guys are just gonna
have to figure is I alright here we go
[ __ ] god dammit god dammit god dammit
there we go I did it huh I got I gotta
be fast because sooner or later people
will catch up with sir my god yeah now
stop stop stop don't go ahead of me
don't go ahead of me go back hey Nevel
aw he's just a show-off you're just a
show-off what a show up I don't need
this just don't whatever you do don't
stand
but 360 yeah that's right that's right I
know a couple minecraft tricks get out
of here bear damn I'm good
360 oh god I actually made it we're
scared there for a second
I prayed a notch every night that's how
I'm so good at this
Jesus Christ hey this is what I'm
talking about this is the minecraft life
life life life not laugh did I make it I
made it I made it this is an epic gamer
moment if this is an epic gamer and
moment I don't know what an epic game or
moment is thank you guys I'm gonna wait
for everyone to make it pass
this is incredible I've never been this
proud what do I get disabled that's
offensive god damn god damn this is what
I'm talking ah God I'm fine I'm actually
fine how about that you guys suck
people actually fallen is that a pimp I
skim I think I saw someone with my face
on it or is it where you go Mike am I
crazy oh god oh god no not like this oh
we're back okay that's fine epic
I'm not playing hi pixel that's ever
[ __ ] suck
okay alright I'm doing another easy
parkour this time we're doing clowns on
level 1 let's freakin do this this is
the most fun I have actually ever had
playing Minecraft I'm not gonna hug God
people oh how are you guys as fast house
[ __ ] I died I think I died alright I go
back [ __ ] died again clouds is hard
man yep [ __ ] I think I jump the wait
list then I [ __ ]
stop swearing Felix it's a god dammit
there's so many people join in I'm
lagging god damn it get out of my way
you pledged
I love you guys I mean [ __ ] this hope
it's hard I got okay I got it hold it
down that's what I'm doing wrong [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] this is really hard when
you don't see anything okay I know it's
there it's gotta believe like a neo did
in the mattress holy [ __ ] I'm actually
dumb as hell why does it jump again oh
god the lag hits you like it hits your
penis oh god [ __ ] it double jump ice
what where did they why my plane this on
ironically this is bad news for everyone
all right let's go back to hub okay I
need I need a head start on everyone I
need a head start I'm gonna pretend guys
I'm not joining anything not doing
anything it's just my face it's just my
face no no no look I'm going over here
I'm joining this one I'm doing this one
yeah yeah yeah this one I'm joining this
one yeah I'm joining this one let's say
I'm doing this one here we go here we go
here we go here we go here we go if
anyone figures out where I am already oh
my god what a hell are you guys this is
same this is same oh I did the epic jump
360 mmm damn I'm good I'm from the
streets of Sweden okay I think I know a
thing or two but parkouring that I think
a lot of you guys don't know about [ __ ]
yeah no I can't see anything now
okay I just get a leap of faith on the
first one okay leap of faith on the
second one
oh cool look at that look at that
what am I looking at here disabled plate
and a HUD disabled player I get hub
let's go back I'm not out let's do
another what up guys I read the chat now
and I don't appreciate it Christine
Skyblock server open nation or maybe
I'll do it next time alright
play something else Valentine's bundle
store egg horse okay egg wash sounds
pretty good
no I don't wanna play solo team battle
to destroy I've got I guess I already
join no I got back here I know what that
means
minor where what is that micro games you
will know oh god there's so many people
survival I should play which one is a
slime survival is that the one you made
alright let's try it I don't see what I
have to lose in slime survival map
selection you just go pirates I don't
think it matters
alright guys play with me poor ones
alright play with me not against me with
me 16000 sub gap here we go bros I don't
know I don't know what I'm doing I'm
actually I'm going there
I'm going there selecting the first
slime what does I mean what does this
mean
okay fat man do oh he don't get it by
chill craft help me the slime has been
released my god
sign will never find me slime will never
find me
[ __ ] you slime [ __ ] you it's lagging
alright it's fine
but it but it slime will never find me
I'm too strong for slime slime can eat
my [ __ ] no weights Kristen got it slime
can eat my ass that's right oh god there
they are
there's two Slimers there's two Slimers
ah this is the most intense gaming woman
out of my life I gotta wash my mouth
while I play this this is actually scary
my god what is this what is this guy
doing does he buy it give me stuff okay
you help me guys you're gonna give away
my Simon's coming guys Sam is gone jewel
Christ you gotta be decoy you gotta take
one for the team man you just gotta take
one for the team mate I don't know why
people bother adding me as a friend when
clearly I'm not gonna exact you [ __ ]
those arts I'm playing Minecraft
understand the importance of it
oh god they'll never get me here they'll
never find me okay if I look here that
will never see me right oh god ah slide
run run oh god I've never been there oh
[ __ ] they're everywhere my god there's
three slimes oh [ __ ] [ __ ] god this is it
Bros instant war what does that do
I can build walls okay guys damn alright
well Peretz I'm bringing this one with
me I can't oh my god
oh god I never been this scared in my
life and I've been through many wars
I've been through many washing my day
I'm gonna be the winner of slang [ __ ]
okay what is this spider web phone I
mean I'll take it I'll take it
speed I got the speed of a thousand
angels by my side fireball fireball god
I'm slow alright come here then you may
have this line laying afraid oh it's a
friend sorry I'm sorry
gomen eyesight alright speed speed oh
god there's five Slimers I repeat
there's five Slimers this is it ah [ __ ]
don't get slammed
zig zag just like they did in the back
of the day gravity explosion [ __ ]
gravity expulsion speed speed speed
[ __ ] what I walked into the slide I
thought it was an item
[ __ ] you Aiden no don't [ __ ] dab on
me [ __ ] you man [ __ ] you man I don't
need this
[ __ ] you man [ __ ] you this [ __ ] sucks
you can't [ __ ] you what are you teeth
never been this angry in my life [ __ ]
this man this [ __ ] sucks man look get
him I'm gonna slimy I'm gonna ice lime
someone ice lime someone yeah that's
right you'll the slime now [ __ ] that's
right it's slime or die [ __ ]
it's slime or die and you died [ __ ]
live the slime how do I get up here
seriously Jojo I don't think so
family friendly I am I am family
friendly youtuber has 12 FPS on
minecraft [ __ ] guys [ __ ] man that was
tough that was real tough I don't know
what to tell you man that was hard
that was really tough me I don't know
why I'm so laggy Jesus Christ 16,000 oh
come on
lobby how do I leave I mean as much as I
enjoyed I'm already in the lobby okay
join the hive
what's the IEP we're playing cubecraft
I think lucky islands tower defense is
usually pretty fun let's let's give that
a go
let's pick one with a low amount in it
there we go
best one okay I got kicked out great
let's do that again I think I may have
crashed the server just a tiny bit [ __ ]
how do I do that oh oh I mean I mean no
I'm not subscribe to PT pi why do I have
Christian symbols next to my name
who did that yes I got the YouTube rank
and the Christian rank sober - PewDiePie
34 are you PT pike no no I'm not why
would you think such a thing
why can I not die
let me in Navi is okay I mean I mean I
mean I mean I'm flying okay this is good
this is good
castle card this is saved bow
this is tower defense someone troops
zombie hello fellow minecraft in capture
the flag
17000 we're destroying t-series playing
minecraft works I knew it I knew it play
apex legends they said game for virgins
I say
Oh God dude there's so many there's so
many how are we going to do this alright
hit one all right hit two
all right I think I think I got this I
think I'm supposed to actually like
build stuff right why is this I don't
understand how I play this settings no
castle at our summit roblox on me I
think I want to some ignore them right
guys help out instead of hitting me how
do I boots up
maybe we can all a build between the
servers well I gotta charge it okay I
got it
look at that I'm basically a wreck going
from Lord of the Rings look at that look
at that headshot
hey Barry [ __ ] off Jesus Christ kill the
zombies not PD play it ain't that hard
bro there it is that's what I'm talking
about
one more this is really fun I really
enjoy the whole like this is super
exciting
I really enjoyed this one make my own
server
what kind of internet do you guys think
I had all right Archie tower how do I
Vince I want to be a long
all right I don't understand how this
one works and I cannot be bothered to
learn okay play cool math games well
that's the hit that's clearly the forth
live stream okay
what is lucky Island then which one
should I play I don't really know which
one to play play murder mystery I don't
see it I do see sky wars so I will play
that okay I'm going to say what one
person sent and I'll play it next time
this is an incredible experience so far
I will say [ __ ] what just happened what
the hell did I just join where am i okay
I got bread I got steak and I got ax and
that's really all you need in life let's
get this bread gamers
yo yo [ __ ] off stop throwing eggs at
peopie alright they're supposed to be on
my site
some to PT PI server update yes 70,000 I
don't understand this one at all but
okay alright dog attack I want you I
want you I won't shoot your [ __ ]
Fricke I killed him
I mean to Jesus what just happened okay
well skywars can suck my ass alright
let's try it another server just for
this hold shift press I of it okay I'll
do that next time I might make it secret
for now just because I don't want to
nuke the server as soon as I join some
background music that's really [ __ ]
quiet
okay I'm supposed to play let's play
something else
[ __ ] I don't remember oh my god he just
died right in front of me free build
might be fun
we can actually like build stuff
together maybe right we can feel like a
big project together you here you here
hi Jen to zoo Den Bosch site all right
warp rebuild warp I can't read it's so
dark
quake bro that's funny
why is it gotta be dark though Oh God
a spider [ __ ] killing our God there's
enemies everywhere I can't die now oh I
forgot you guys can't see the game I'm
safe
how do I open inventory q no R
mm-hmm man minecraft this changed a lot
I don't know what's going on but this is
the life
oh god what is happened why does he have
a golden armor god damn back in my day
all you did was build a little house and
I was in oh god people figured out where
I am in this server is getting [ __ ]
that's the doorman server will no [ __ ]
and we just nuked it I'm sorry I really
don't mean to destroy this Aaron what's
the server that will take a lot of
people 18,000 anything what's a server
that will take a lot of people and we
can actually just build sup I think that
might be fun just tell me I'm here I'm
listening bros everyone's hypixel
it was the worst experience of my life
none of the commands work mine place
everyone from high pixel high pixel
alright [ __ ] it we're back since you
guys won't shut up oh my [ __ ] god
Jesus Christ this is [ __ ] nightmare
okay so then all right I'm in hypixel
where do I join and how to [ __ ] do I get
down from here okay so if I wanna build
with you guys
where do I join and how do I get down
from here like what the [ __ ] why am i
flying space goes up which one goes down
shift okay look at this this is insane
it's actual madness then I'm ready to
turn out the brightness because I have
lights on me and it's really hard to see
okay that's better
I didn't even join anything I think I
think probably mods are watching this
dream and they can't just put in me
places god I'm scared what is this I did
not join this what is happening alright
oh god alright I'm somewhere else now
fantastic
all right I'm so confused build battle
okay
no battling just jump building together
as a family am i voting theme wail oh
okay am I supposed to be a whale is that
what's happening here
oh god I'm so confused okay I have
different colors
I never play my grounds so long
all right let's build the whale [ __ ] all
right it's fine it's fine
it's mine I'm building a whale how much
time do I have how much time do I have
to build this whale
how do whales look like sorry one second
what is a whale I need a reference I
know what a whale is I'm just trolling
you guys Jesus of course I know what a
whale is Tony but build build build
ain't got all day I am building the best
whale I've ever seen in my life should I
build a 3d whale or two they bail am I
actually saying whale or well I think I
have time to build a 3d male let's do it
let's do it 3d
that's the most fun I had in Hawley I
honestly
I mean heaven alright that way look like
right how much time I have three minutes
god damn it running low
18500 three minutes remaining let's
build this well okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay all right okay okay okay
okay okay
all right we got to get the symmetry we
got to get that whale symmetry I'm gonna
have to go sicko mode on this minecraft
build base to say this is the way this
is gonna be the best whale you guys have
ever seen anyone that watches his
livestream is crying right now
because his whale is so goddamn
beautiful alright we're gonna have to do
the face okay we still have time we
still have time alright we got plenty of
time to build this whale [ __ ] I'm not
flying anymore
okay okay game playing playing playing
don't panic what would not just do right
now that's all I ask
okay I need white blocks that's it two
minutes remaining
oh god oh god I'm freaking out what is
that supposed to be it's this faves
Felix okay why are you talking to
yourself because I'm nervous and I'm
playing Minecraft Oh God alright okay
okay alright okay okay don't freak out
but your whale looks terrible I'm trying
okay this is it this is it that's a
whale if that ain't a whale oh god I'm
gonna win first price I realize that
what should I do with this newly
acquired fame that if kar-wai whale
maybe how much time do I left a minute
okay we have time we have time we have
time we
Oh God but the block the block in my ass
honey buckets of [ __ ] [ __ ] where's my
inventory oh god you've done it now
there it is oh god oh god please please
forgive me God Brian mr. minecraft it
looks like a car it looks like a car
shut that [ __ ] up you take tube and that
person and that person right now we're
saying it look like a car I will not
stand for the Cybernet bullying [ __ ] you
it does not look like a car it looks
like a whale this is it I'm doing a
heart by the way that's a hard how do I
build a hard [ __ ] my god a lot of time
why have hearts so hard to make ok wait
how does heart look like that's a heart
right that's a heart right
right gone six minutes remaining
oh oh oh I forgot I forgot about the
stream no oh god please win okay all
right how do I vote please vote for me
please what is this what does it say
okay what did you say I didn't look at
it Oh God sub to pew oh that's a whale
that's a whale that's terrible
what is this that's what you spend all
your time making pathetic I'll give it
an okay okay all right what is this oh
my god that is actually terrible super
poop
yeah Wow all right whatever get what did
we get their self advertising this is
bad
yeah I agree I agree all right this is
creative maybe it's like you're watching
an angle no it isn't this is dolphins as
dolphins you loser not a whale sub -
PewDiePie tick series no that's epic I'm
giving that an epic very nice very nice
oh my god
ten maritime legendary legendary Wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ] fish this is me Moby Dick's dick
what is this wait is that Japan and okay
okay what is this T series
[Music]
[Applause]
terrible what is this thing
sub - Shaun something else
terrible Wow you trying to self
advertise sub 2
I don't know what it says but I'd well
Wow
terrible condom how many are there
that's a whale I'll look into that
I'll get that an epic that's pretty epic
that's a pretty epic whale I'm not gonna
lie that's pretty epic whale epic whale
guess the build okay I'm sorry but that
was [ __ ] awful was that supposed to
be Pearl Harbor before what the [ __ ] why
would you build that nineteen thousand
and I won minecraft alright whoever's
rivers modding this has refreshed me cuz
I want to play with new people could you
refresh me to join a new one while I
take a leak really quick
alright I'm gonna do
[Music]
I'm back broski's holy cow all right
where am I now
okay mod mod guy please put me back in
put me back in I'm gonna play that again
that was fun
sub gap nineteen forty four thousand
brooch I don't know what you're doing
but you're goddamn legends we're doing
it this is it this is it this is the end
game I'll play another one after this
one but I want to play that again Thank
You mod guy I don't know who you are but
you're making it very good for me thank
you very much what is this no no no I
asked to be put in the game look I just
oh god that's bad for me isn't it
it's called billboards no it isn't stop
lying
I'm just gonna fall for eternity now god
I'm getting like an invite every second
all right let me back in then I guess I
guess I'll have to do it myself
the server is like okay now it works
thank you
okay god it's so laggy
what is this bill wash I want to play
bill hard all right Let Me In Bell wash
duels prove your worth in hypixel doers
friend requests privacy anyone can send
you pray workers no no thanks what the
hell is is for freak Oh God
the bridge guess I'm playing the bridge
just because of that beautiful name one
verse is one bridge this is it my
Redemption arc oh god is it oh god no oh
god yeah oh he's building he's building
how did he know how to build
oh you'll regret this what is he doing
come here big luck oh that's the point
of the game to go to the other side
I lost already [ __ ] up he's gonna get it
what is he doing it's yeah hit or miss
ah
oh how that son of a snake come back
here how do you do that son of a snake
you got moved son I'll admit that I
admit you got moved walking so fast all
right you know what [ __ ] you big [ __ ]
trihard oh god leave Leeds please I
guess it's too full lion if you're
watching the live stream be gentle okay
it's the first time I play do you guess
that's how it is it's just some people
just got to be like that what the [ __ ]
is all this it's so confusing guess the
build sure guess the build everyone
we're guessing the build yes pewdiepie
come on 20,000 abuse is banned Apple
don't abuse guys no abusing guess what
other people guess what other players
are trying to build I got that once it's
your turn to be able to select the theme
and tried to build fast the image being
selected okay
[Music]
all right Ryan s what do you got all
right Ryan nice what do you got huh
you think you're tough [ __ ] earnest
build Ryan s Bell floor changer you're
not building rhinos oh [ __ ] he's not
Billy what an [ __ ]
oh he's Billy okay so we got black
blocks for them all right what else
what is he building where does Ryan is
building
okay he's building more black stuff what
could this be a furnace no what else
could this be a Tesla one minute
remaining Rheinische one minute
remaining I don't think you're doing a
very good job Ryan ouch God what is this
a portal it's a portal rhino's
Rheinische okay what it's it's an animal
coming out of the portal it's a cooking
pot it's a witch brew I don't know this
is a Minecraft thing cuz I don't know
the Minecraft side
y'all okay all right guys help me help
me black black ding ding how drunk it's
magic really rhino you idiot pathetic i
pimp Smurf it wasn't a calendar and to
stop I pimp Smurf what do you got what
do you got pimp Smurf stop saying
caldron it wasn't a [ __ ] caldron God
all right we got weird stuff a carrot or
carrots guys help I don't this giraffe I
don't notice spelled you're an ass
what the [ __ ] is there's a lion tiger
god damnit oh so close [ __ ] all right
Benji let's see what you got Benji it's
a cow sir it's not a caldron okay all
right Benji all right Benji what do you
got Benji
you think you're tough [ __ ] Benji
all right buddy we got
what waterful I don't know
lasagna a caldron fountain for [ __ ]
sake you man
Oh what is it my turn a bill if I don't
want to come as calibre and again I
swear to [ __ ] god yeah there's no
point you're saying fountain now after
is that xxxx 10th St on [ __ ] oh ok what
do we get
what do we get do ex proud come on what
do you got
what is this Scooby got waves
what is he building one minute remaining
all right what do we got penis
let's see penis pee pew pew pew pew
peb dirty house what the hell oh god
what is this it looks like a calendar I
shut the [ __ ] up
it wasn't even a caldron Jesus Christ
all right what do we got all right show
us shall wash what do you got Scooby got
waves its teeth [ __ ] serious god
[ __ ] damn me shut the [ __ ] up twenty
thousand we're twenty thousand away god
damn it I don't know what you guys are
doing while I do these live streams are
you making extra cash all right what
else so you're gonna type in two seconds
for aah
fry freon
freeing friend find T friend good one he
probably never wanted ya t frying
different oh yeah
different me friend me
[Laughter]
the theme is I'm not gonna friend you
stop wasting your time Jesus Christ even
if I do I'm not gonna play the game
anymore
this is a suicide hotline friend me bab
al dab there you go that's all yeah
friend me what is he doing all right
CB flex I'm sorry but you [ __ ] suck
all right
well Sam I gotta find you if you build a
t-series log Oh dad friend me dad no dad
it's my turn okay
okay birds or race car or enderdragon
I'll do a bird okay this is my chance
this is my chance to actually make
something of myself if someone gets it
already no we're good
all right guys ix someone [ __ ] strips
night
you [ __ ] strange sniper let me build
my bird yeah god damned who was it I'm
gonna ban you or ban all of you [ __ ]
this [ __ ] all of you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
piece of [ __ ] stream snipers ah why I
want build wars build war Oh a mean
build worst okay so little battle again
I'm doing it [ __ ] you guys I'll join
another server after this one it'll be
epic
okay wait sorry what theme we're waiting
for a theme maze it gets together one
amazing mine orange glass is barbecue
I don't know orange maybe I don't
[ __ ] know how do I even vote
I don't care all right we're doing
orange Jesus Christ okay I like the
music all right so we're gonna we're
gonna start off by a picket of orange
we're gonna start off from the bottom up
we're gonna build the best goddamn
orange this town has ever known
learning notch will stop whatever he's
doing right now just to be impressed by
this orange okay literally all the other
streams will shut down just to watch
this stream of me building a [ __ ]
orange okay that's the kind of level
we're talking about that's the kind of
next level or injury that we are doing
orange or Die basically at this it
doesn't even look anywhere four minutes
we got four minutes that's fine that's
plenty of time
do not panic on me now Felix you're not
panic [ __ ] I look like think again okay
[Music]
relax you're gonna be fine
we're gonna be fine
my wife is gonna leave spell the [ __ ]
orange Felix I'm building the orange
it's fine it's fine it's fine I'm
building an orange and bailing annoying
something an orange I decided to go big
and I really regret going big on this
[Music]
building
visiting a mother [ __ ] goddamned
[ __ ] orange that if that does not
look like an orange to you I'm sorry
have you seen an orange three minutes
that's fine how do I do
okay well let's rely on some flavor to
will add some flavor to it it will be
fine when we find maybe if you had a
smiley face maybe you have a smiley face
they'll be alright
there are they're smaller bulbs forgive
me Father it's kind of things
[Music]
I'm sorry I'm sorry I had to spice it up
okay
how much time left two minutes we have
two minutes time left okay so detailing
we do the details now that's fine so all
about the details more said more goddamn
it
face to see one minute okay so now it's
all about - fine fine details that's
gross what are you talk it's an orange
[Music]
no no no it's got it oh of course he's
orange it's got an orange D [ __ ] I'm so
stupid this is not Christian what the
hell are you talking about bill till I
die
bill till I die this is gonna win it's
gonna win it boys what the hell is that
sub is that loss no it isn't [ __ ] off
no I get to okay yeah okay all right
what did we that's not an orange these
are terrible dude there's an OST series
do you think you're funny
what are you put here you're into
pyramid that's great
all right fine decent zero however I'm
sorry
all right what is it it's a bro fish all
right we got a text saying what keep
doing what you're doing please magazine
your giraffe game or YouTube or my IGN I
love you okay great thank you very much
i inferior to you well you got that
goddamn right what the [ __ ] is this
supposed to be substitutes this is why
you spend your time doing all right what
else we got yo salty
okay all right he wants me to read also
my build no I'm not gonna do that
[ __ ] hell it's not that hard oh this
is your orange oh that's kind of cool I
like that one I guess an epic we kind of
went with the same ideal personifying
the orange which at least I can respect
all right what else we got really it's
not even even 0-0 it was the bridge
goddamn a subterfuge 20,000 almost 30
million I mean 21 [ __ ] well
a little ahead of myself all right love
boots thank you that was very nice
subscribe to no no I'm not
what do you think I'm here all right
what do we got here
sorry had to pee I can respect that
I can respect that that was all right
they don't give you enough time to
really appreciate sub to whine name band
okay
these orange is pathetic though I
appreciate the Russian flying those sub
computer 512 I guess in the legionary oh
that's mine
oh that's mine I didn't rely where's my
penis where's my penis Oh magnifiers my
penis
hey there files man you like pyramids oh
god oh my god that was amazing no more
though no more all right I got that
where's my [ __ ] penis all right
there's a mother a game modes
I guess [ __ ] Jesus Christ
I want to go to main lobby oh god it
really got dark man and me got
circumcised Jesus oh excuse me
all right I'll listen to the last
suggestions and I'll play whatever you
guys want me to play I really don't
think it matters at this point sorry I'm
gonna join a new server 21 thousand bros
Jesus Christ absolutely incredible I'm
connecting to a server I think it's
working okay well this one didn't work
let's try another one
you got banned from minecraft good job
minecraft I'm not bad
only from some bed force a lot of people
are saying bed wars what server do I
play bed wars on I think I might have to
go to back to high pixel because it's
the only one that works and they were
actually helpful and for me to play it
so I appreciate that okay I got high
pixel bed Wars is that on that is that
on this one bed wars [ __ ] pen boys
you guys really like - I guess so you
guys can play as well bed dwarfs where
bish we're build that all okay someone
took care of it for me all right so what
is bed wars then what do I do
hmm oh god everyone's in here alright
let's read this you're in three
teammates battle for control of
dreamscape gather gold blah blah blah to
build to buy items and upgrades for you
and your team and every team resident
this seems pretty complicated I don't
know if I want to play this every team
has yeah I'm not playing this [ __ ] you
guys
are there suggestions I'll listen the
stream is lagging refresh your browser
and stop complaining 21500 our report
Peter pious streaming please please
don't report oh god it like
hide-and-seek sure let's do
hide-and-seek then let's find it
let's find hide-and-seek why are you
hiding hide-and-seek I don't see it
ironically I can't find heightens knee
anything else
Oh someone took care of it thank you
okay how am I gonna play hide and seek
if you guys are washing my [ __ ] okay
pixel painters finding out of football
football sounds fun let's do that
there's so many modes I can't believe it
we're playing football
okay
play genital jousting yeah cuz I hate ad
revenue that much where's the ball
where's the ball is that the ball
they're nice how do I kick it this is so
confusing
I don't want to resourcepack I went away
oh god this reminds me of when I played
football in high school
oh there too everyone chasing the ball
I'm just like this is [ __ ] boring
okay I got the ball look I did it where
is he Oh God it's not even a ball it's
this
okay this is pretty boring I don't know
man I thought that was like an actual
football it's really hard to see like
what's going on let's go back to hug
like that
you need to pack to see it oh so I don't
have to okay I get it all right - we got
party games zombie
oh there's hide-and-seek where are we
what the hell is goin on alright don't
[ __ ] cheat then the dirt stairs oh
you've gone the knuckles Wow and sans
crossover incredible alright second
becomes props right let's click to stun
right clip two prompts one oh I am an
axe now okay this is so dumb no one will
ever know it's me the seeker is on the
loose the seeker better not cheat that's
all I'm saying
oh god oh there he is he doesn't cheat
this is gonna be streamed snipe no no no
no no no this is not gonna be screams
night you know why you kept the [ __ ]
outta here you mean expose me
stop stop dude just stay still
at least say so thank you there you go
oh god there's two of them stop exposing
me just go oh god I am so scared oh my
god I lived I lived they're not watching
the livestream oh god stop oh god oh god
it's working it's working
idiot no no no no no no no no no no stop
stop stop this [ __ ] is watching the
live sake [ __ ] man
god dammit okay alright alright this
exhibition check oh I see it's a tiger
thanks okay great you know what this I
don't think this game will work because
clearly I'm just gonna get stream
tonight I don't think it works
hey look it's Donald Trump everyone and
dragon Wars creeper attack okay that
sounds fun let's do that murder mystery
okay I'll do that after this one
damn okay all right someone didn't tell
me the Minecraft that's [ __ ] sexy I
look oh sorry madam excuse me
all right so what's the point of this I
didn't look at the rules Morgan Freeman
I'm sorry you got up hey we're playing
together
where's the creepers my fellow bros we
will fight against the creepers 22000
[ __ ] you creepers [ __ ] Freeman
step aside there's Hunger Games on this
that's the real plan maybe I should play
that cuz I don't have that much time
your life I want to play something
actually interesting alright still
having games because everyone won't shut
up about it
mint mod Sun police put me in Hunger
Games ever got to go show him ass do you
have Hunger Games in this server thank
you oh damn they're fast
alright survival games teams alright
well I guess it's over here maybe I
should do two teams cuz I feel like
everyone's gonna [ __ ] me over
and stream snipe me I can't believe I'm
actually playing this
what is happening okay we got to go fast
oh god oh god forgive me what is this
[Music]
watch the [ __ ] I'm getting [ __ ] [ __ ]
Lilly cool you did it guys good job
[ __ ] out guys
you had one job let's do another one
[ __ ] hell this minecraft try-hards I
thought we played teams now God is a
bridge
he's just delaying the advert inevitable
who dare say that how dare you already
hitting me literally I'm innocent
I haven't done anything [ __ ] that I'm
just gonna run away
[Music]
get any worse than this Oh beg Dwarfs
let me go through that already and it
was terrible I don't remember yeah I was
too complicated I couldn't be wedding
it's sad that poor and I ripped off this
I agree is that mr. beast or fake mr.
beast I can't tell thank you very much
either way fake or real mr. beast no
murder mystery is there any game I can
play that like isn't affected by stream
sniping it's clearly these [ __ ] kids
we're just trying to be like build
battle we didn't that party games sure
let's do party game whatever that is
whatever this is I don't know okay okay
what's a good one then like a brain-dead
one a real dumb one okay let's do it
then you know what let's change
[Music]
one second I did Network
can't connect anything now
[Music]
cheese says okay so what's like a
creative server that I can join in so we
can build a [ __ ] I think that might be
fun I'm trying to find out
let's try it out got it thank you
22,000 that's what I'm talking about
[ __ ] I don't need any [ __ ] super
smash bros I know you can't see the
stream that's the point
[Applause]
people already find me that's pretty
nice
Hubbs are we gonna vote for the next man
I don't know what this is my belly
builder since when I feel like such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] because I don't
understand how my crap works anymore
you so simple goddamnit
oh I'm literally playing the same
[ __ ] game I played no pirate
the theme is pirate oh gee I wonder if
anyone's gonna guess it am I done let's
build the [ __ ] pirate best the best
pirate I've ever seen you can feel
this is gonna be a partner this is gonna
be the best goddamn fire this town has
ever seen
y'all never seen a pirate like this
voice oh my god this pirate though
honestly I think
ready I want advice it's gonna be the
best pirate oh my god guys don't even
get me started on this pirate
I build a dispenser I want to build at
his bedside goddammit I just wanna feel
normal stop I think you can tell it'll
play if this doesn't change the sub down
I don't know what will
[Music]
thank you for that prompt because
honestly
actually very focused right now this is
a important moment for this channel
that's it that's it that's it I feel it
I feel it in my finger
yes I went wait done we ain't done boys
we ain't done I got two minutes left
boys
Oh Oh the place is here oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh sorry oh I'm sorry oh I'm sorry
oh I'm sorry oh yeah oh yes son this is
what I'm talking about [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is it this is it this is the end
game that's supposed to be an ass by the
way kids
let's add the brown
dirty I like that
fine
that's nasty
that's nasty you're nasty
you're nasty gap Oh God oh I don't even
wanna look at you yeah yeah see what I'm
talking about 23-thousand Jesus Lord
Almighty I knew this would work I knew
this would work I think it needs some
more some more poopsies I still can't
press the right button family my 23 323
300 big boys he's pretending to be a
noob he places everyday you're right
you're right I've been exposed
[ __ ] always looks like something else
now that's it my magnum opus this is say
oh my god how my build time over real
time over all right what do we got what
do we get sub to pewds amazing I don't
know how you guys got in there so fast
god damn let's impress it honestly Loki
oh my god sub-2 sub-3 face
brofist epic brofist in the chat boys
this is it
incredible work what have we got here
you [ __ ] yes amazing Jojo amazing
incredible how the [ __ ] you're so
fast I'm honestly amazed that you found
me okay what is this then tea vagina
that's right
tea vagina T series can you not shove
your [ __ ] face in there sub tap out
you heard it here first Minecrafters sub
Tibet's hazy amazing
we got sign substitute substitute what
what what who did this oh my god oh my
god I'm freaking out no just kidding oh
oh thank god
I was about to delete minecraft holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's an X that's an actual
pretty badass pirate you did it you
follow the theme
or without some guy sub the birds and
the pirate ship waited without that
Quinton great job you did it give me a
20 million
this one is incredible t-series eat ass
this is magnificent I love this who
built this lmao honestly Wow
sub the birds nope I'm gonna let that
furry emote slide figure something out
and it's lasagna flavored I love it mwah
I love it
all right what is this one I paid at
YouTube my name is okay don't care hi
YouTube have a nice day
flame I'm sorry but I think you think
you build the worst one so far I've got
okay here we got a bunch of signs that
says sub defeated by okay alright okay
alright subs a bit about alright okay
alright alright okay okay we got okay
right okay very good
sub what the [ __ ] is that
alright shut up no no furry emotes in my
chance stop it
that's an actual pirate I can respect
that
I respect that mom I'm on YouTube
but don't pull out meat simply stop it
what is this what the [ __ ] is this
Troy is hard all right that's [ __ ]
terrible I'm sorry Troy I'm sorry
hey team start one everyone it's a
caldron
it's a caldron we close the gap at
twenty three thousand six hundred easy
and I played Minecraft was it painful
absolutely will I do it again most
probably not but did we do it
abso-fucking-lutely incredible amazing
23,000 I think that will make us live
for another one or two days dear god I'm
desperate Jesus Christ
alright guys thanks for watching this
live stream I hope you had fun I
wouldn't say that I had fun but mediocre
fun I would call it the most important
bit is where the [ __ ] did everything
just go
Oh
hey guys Jesus Christ havoc what does
happen did you guys see that I don't
know if you saw that cheeks is quite all
right this is it cool math games is next
see you guys then
thank you for joining F big profits all
around town it build that bro face